إن مناقشة الوزير بن جابر تؤدي في الواقع إلى تعقيد العلاقات
دولة إسرائيل مع الإدارة الأمريكية كما يقول
في مقابلة مع صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال بدلا من أن تعطينا
الدعم الكامل لبايدن المنشغل بالمساعدات الإنسانية الضعيفة
مساعدات لغزة
هذا الوقود قادم
والطعام يذهب لحماس لو كان ترامب في السلطة
ويقول بن جابر سلوك الولايات المتحدة
أن تكون مختلفًا تمامًا لا يفيد
أعتقد بالنسبة للعلاقة بين الحكومتين
الأمر الذي يضع الإدارة بشكل أساسي في مأزق
ربما كيف يمكن أن تكون إدارة
لقد وقف بايدن إلى جانب إسرائيل بطريقة ناقصة حقًا
سابقة عندما يدفع Bean حقًا سعرًا ملموسًا مقابل ذلك
في انتخاباته، لا أعتقد أنه كان هناك زعيم آخر
على استعداد للذهاب إلى حد بعيد لصالح إسرائيل أو
دولة أخرى يعرفها تؤذي قاعدته
لأننا نعلم مدى أهمية القاعدة للقادة
الآخرين وبدون أدنى شك أن بن جفير قرر الآن ذلك
الذهاب إلى المجال الدولي ثم الناس في الإدارة
يرى الناخبون أن يقولوا ما نقدمه لهم
وهذه هي الطريقة التي يرد بها لنا الجميل، إنه هجوم كبير جدًا حقًا
لا سمح الله بايدن والأميركيين لم يكونوا مهمين
هنا في بعض التصريحات يتم تجميع دولة إسرائيل
لكنها كانت ستكون هناك لو لم يكن بن جفير موجودا
سيكون من الجيد لو كان بن جوير على حق بشأن هذا الشيء الوحيد
لو كان ترامب لكان نتنياهو قد قبل
هاتف أو تطرده أو تقدم المساعدة لإسرائيل
دعونا نتوقف، دعونا نتذكر فقط ما فعله الرئيس الأمريكي
بالنسبة لإسرائيل منذ اليوم السابع من شهر أكتوبر فهو في الواقع
لقد اعتنى بأكثر من 100 طائرة هبطت هنا وما زالت تفعل ذلك
إنهم يهبطون هنا كل يوم محملين بذخائر المعارضة
للحصول على موافقة الكونجرس لم يحصل بعد على موافقة الكونجرس
وبموافقة طارئة، قام بالفعل بتحويل المساعدات إلى إسرائيل
بمبلغ يزيد عن ملياري دولار صحيح
وهو يتحدث في هذه اللحظة عن حزمة مساعدات لإسرائيل
من 14 مليار دولار وضع اثنين هنا
حاملات الطائرات أعطت إسرائيل الحماية السياسية
بشكل غير مسبوق، فقد تجاوزوا أيضًا كل مرحلة
هناك حاجة ماسة إلى الأهداف الإسرائيلية من الحرب
افهم هذه الصفقة لأننا نتحدث عنها
كثيرًا ولكن ليس مثل الاتفاق السابق أن هناك حفلة
طرف واحد واثنان يضعان اللمسات النهائية على الصفقة.هناك مرحلتان هنا
والتي تتعارض تمامًا مع الخطوة الأولى التي سأقرأها
إذا كان هناك مسرح إسرائيلي هنا، فسنحصل على الكثير ولا
إنهم يمنحون الكثير من الأخوة ويعطون وقف إطلاق النار لمدة ستة أسابيع
وهذا في الواقع ليس بالأمر الفظيع من وجهة نظر إسرائيل
فيما يلي بعض الاحتياجات التشغيلية التي تتأثر بالبحر 35
المختطفون لأسباب إنسانية هم كبار السن والمرضى والنساء
وخمس جنديات أخريات نواجه صعوبة في التعامل معهن
ومن المفترض أن يطلقوا سراح عدد معقول من الحراس وليس أنت
والأثقل، أقصد حتى الآن نتنياهو أيضاً
سياسيا يستطيع أن يمررها يستطيع أن يعيش
مع ذلك، كل هذه هي المرحلة الأولى، والآن المرحلة الثانية هي كل شيء
الأكبر وأعني المرحلة الثانية والعلاقة بينهما
حقًا لأن هامز يقول أنه بعد المرحلة الأولى سيتم ختانك
بالنسبة لنا، فمن الصحيح أنه لن يكون لديك الجنود كما هو الحال الآن
الأمر صعب جدًا بالنسبة لإسرائيل، لكنك تلقيت استمرارًا
القتال ليس لديك أي تراجع، لقد حصلت على كل شيء
شعبك وأنت لم تقم بتعيين الأثرياء
في الخطوة ب يجب عليك أن تفجر الأثقل مما هم عليه
نتمنى لو أننا سمعنا الأسماء من عنوان في البرغوثي
وشمالاً إلى مهندسي هجمات تيب دي
والثانية للإرهابيين الآن كما يقولون
مجنون وتراجع وتوقف عن القتال وبعد ذلك تحصل
إذا جاز التعبير، الجنود حتى لو لم يكن هناك استراحة
القتال النهائي الذي من المفترض أن تقوم به هو العملية الوحيدة
ثلاثة أشهر تعني أنك بالفعل أربعة
من الصعب جدًا تجديد شهر ونصف من عدم القتال
ومن بعد ذلك، وبالتالي هذا الاتصال بين اثنين
الخطوات هي القصة الكبيرة الكاملة لحماس والاتفاق
يحكي حاز عما قالته له أخته جوردان رومان
جات عندما عادت من الأسر وقالت إنها نضجت حقًا
أسرها سمعت الإذاعة الإسرائيلية هناك وسمعت
السياسيون الذين يشرحون سبب عدم حاجتها إليها
للعودة إلى المنزل، تبلغ ابنتها جيفن ثلاث سنوات وأنا
أريد أن أقول لسياسيينا إنكم تستطيعون ذلك
لقول الكثير من الأشياء، ضع في اعتبارك أن المختطفين هم أيضًا
نحن الذين عليهم أن يواجهوا كل دقيقة في الأنفاق
من هم يسمعون كلامك إلا كلمة واحدة
قال لذلك قمت مرة أخرى بقياس عمر الإعلام
السياسيون يصمتون في الغالب لأنهم يسمعون
وهذا أيضا في الأنفاق
في غزة